we bout to feast can't wait to eat hey
guys its Anka I made a BuzzFeed and
before I came to BuzzFeed I was
backpacking on a trainer for couple
months I really miss it and I really
miss the food there so today I'm gonna
try to find some of my favorite Chinese
foods here in New York City and I'm
gonna bring a friend along with me
we're gonna go to three different
restaurants each representing three
different types of Chinese cuisines and
we'll see which one we like best at all
but it's so beautiful here I am
SuperDuper excited like it smells
amazing
I think has been raving about this is
this better be really really good
[Music]
it's basically this type of flatbreads
around some really really flavorful meat
I've also seen them make this and she on
it put it in like the oven it just
slowly becomes this crunch on the
outside this is so good oh my god
[Music]
we have two different types of noodles
right now they're both hands cooled it's
like the piece of dole and then they
stretch it out until it's like super
long for Mom and then that's basically
it this is the hot oil seared noodles
which is the vegan option and then this
one is the spice and cumin lamb this
look at a dripping really long turning
using the bottom up
Chinese soul food right here y'all cuz
I'm it's getting my soul right now yeah
I'm assuming that you're gonna be pretty
excited about where we're gonna happen I
am very excited right now look I had no
idea this existed yet check let's move
on to the next place I have never
what is this only a lot of little plates
of food everybody kind of gathers around
and like you know you have to family it
I grew up eating this I feel like it's
such like a big part of my childhood I
really really want you to like
[Music]
I love shrimp so I cannot wait to just
consume all of that this trip is really
fresh was this some some next-level
shrimp right here
do you like yeah I love this it seems as
if they're like they get their sperm
straight from the omelet
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] like they shifted here
just for this day just for I pestered
buns don't normally come like this but I
am not complaining
[Music]
this was magnificent I'd eat it prep as
much and dinner just to let you know
that one's fine I'm so happy that you
brought me along for this that means a
lot to me to know that somebody has
never had it before is like really into
this so now that we've had can't hog
disease we're gonna move on and go to
our next stop Nana are you ready for
this I was born ready
[Music]
I am like super into spicy food and
citron is basically like where you want
to be for like let's see if you can take
the heat today
this already looks like really different
this is very like stylized when you put
it in your mouth it's like a mini
explosion of flavor it has all the sauce
it has all the flavor they make their
own kung pao sauce here
and maybe that's why it tastes so good
[Music]
it looks like fire like liquid fire
this looks like it has an exorbitant
amount of spice on it
this is so good hello fish oh my gosh
it's like a little hint of spice here
and there and it's really good it's not
this place that makes you feel like oh
my god when you thought I'm Chinese when
you never thought of things like this
right at all wait Adam now what do you
think of Chinese food I think Chinese
food is next level we've been to three
restaurants kind of three types of food
from like three different provinces I'm
gonna start coming out to plush and more
often take that trip because this food
is perfect I think this is an area that
we're both gonna see if we can come back
and like get some real good I do this
more often today was a great day
it sure was car they went by you
[Music]